but first labor and opposition parties
are threatening to launch proceedings
for contempt of parliament unless the
legal advice given by the Attorney
General to the Prime Minister on her
brexit plan is published in full so
let's talk now to the man behind this
circus Dharma the shadow brexit
secretary thank you for being on the
show this morning so just explain what
is it you're trying to do here well as
you've just said in nine days time
Parliament's got to take probably the
most important decision is taken for a
generation and it's obviously important
we know the full legal implications of
what the Prime Minister wants us to sign
up to so we had a debate about two weeks
ago in Parliament where we said we need
the full legal advice from the Attorney
General the final advice at the end of
that debate Parliament ordered the
government to produce that advice now it
is exceptional to have that advice
produced to Parliament but that was the
order the government at that stage two
weeks ago had the opportunity to vote
against that order and they didn't they
abstain so there's that order the
government now says we're not going or
looks as if it's going to say we're not
going to comply with the order so as it
were having pushed Parliament away for
weeks and months if it's now moving into
the territory of ignoring Parliament all
together and breaching an order of
Parliament then we're getting into very
very deep water and you're talking about
contempt of Parliament proceedings I
mean what does that mean that what can
actually do can you force the government
to publish it yeah I mean the first
thing I should say is I don't want to go
down this path I said to the government
two weeks ago and I said to them last
week do the right thing you've been
ordered to produce this advise just
produce it if they don't produce it
tomorrow then we will start contempt
proceedings this will be a collision
course between the government and
Parliament that then has to be debated
in the house and an order can be made of
contempt now as I say I don't want to go
down this path with nine days to go
before this fate we shouldn't be dealing
with contempt of parliament but at the
moment for the government to say the one
hand we're not going to vote against the
order being made and then to turn round
if it does turn around tomorrow and say
but we're not going to comply with the
order is to get themselves into really
deep water the government has said
that it will publish a summary yeah I
mean why is that not good enough well
you need the full hearing because there
is an argument isn't there that it's
important for the government to be able
to have your honest and frank
conversations with their legal advisors
of course it is and that's why the
convention is that the Attorney
General's legal advice is not disclosed
except in exertion in exceptional
circumstances and these are exceptional
circumstances now when we had that
discussion in Parliament I was offered a
summary now having been a lawyer for
many years I know I've seen a lot of
summaries of legal advice and summaries
I'm not as good as the full legal advice
and they tend to leave out the bits that
the author of the summary doesn't want
people to know about so we said no to a
summary we said we want the full legal
advice and that was there what we voted
on and at the end of the debate the
speaker asked whether the government
wanted to oppose that order and they
chose not to so I think your Brandon
Lewis on blatant maybe ask him why they
didn't vote against the order if they
now say they shouldn't have to comply
with it you mentioned there that you
have been a lawyer obviously had been a
Norfolk a very long time and how many
times have you made your legal advice
public your private legal advice to
clients well on a number of occasions
lawyers make their advice public but
we're talking about a different issue
here we're talking about the Attorney
General's advice to the cabinet on the
legal implications of the agreement that
the prime minister wants us to sign up
to I accept that is exceptional to have
that disclosed it has happened in the
past but is it is exceptional that's why
we had a debate in Parliament to say is
this the sort of case where it's so
exceptional that it should be disclosed
and at the end of that debate the house
could have divided we could have the
government could have voted against it
but it didn't so I can't come along now
and say well we didn't vote against this
order but now we don't want to comply
with I mean is there also an argument
that we effectively know what that legal
advice is coming well well this is the
thing I mean now this morning on the
front page of The Sunday Times you see
that whilst the prime minister in the
Attorney General on one hand are saying
MPs can't see this advice leaked bits of
the advice are now getting into the
media
that can only have come from the cabinet
this advice is only being with the
company so you've got this situation
where somebody in and around the cabinet
who's seen this advice has got bits of
it to the Sunday Times so the journalist
and the edges at Sunday Times knows more
about this illegal advice than I do
this really is so unacceptable and now
we've got this key vote in pawn yeah and
coming up and more than 100 Conservative
MP is indicating that they're not happy
with the deal on the table so I want to
know what you're planning to do if
Theresa May loses that vote will you
call it motion of no confidence in her
well we've got nine days to go we'll
have to see which way the vote goes but
it looks like a considerable number of
Tory MPs are going to vote against it it
looks as though you DUP or not and the
opposition parties not so I think the
Prime Minister as we all know is going
to struggle between now and that vote
and people sort of praise her resilience
at the moment I don't think this is
resilience it's just plowing or what
will you do if she loses that vote the
legislation that we've already passed
says she must come back to the house and
make a statement about what she's going
to do next now technically she's got 21
days to do that but she'll probably come
back the next day so we need to see what
that is but it seems to me that if the
Prime Minister has lost a vote of that
sort of significance then there has to
be a question of confidence in the
government so will you seek to move that
I think it's inevitable that we will
seek to move that obviously it'll depend
on what actually happens in nine days
it'll depend on what the response is but
if she's lost a vote on this
significance after two years of
negotiation then it is right that there
should be a general election because but
for the fixed term Parliament act the
convention was always if a government
loses what's called a confidence vote
something of such significance then that
government has to go and you clearly
want to see a general election that's
been Labour's policy for a long time and
but I'm keen to press you on the second
referendum yes question as well because
there it does appear you know from an
observers point of view that Labour's
position has been shifting that you've
been warming to the idea of a second
referendum is that something that you
let me just set out how we thought this
through because we had a good discussion
about this at our Party conference in
September and we tried to look at the
decisions but we would have slightly
confused discussion wasn't it less
people it was a good discussion of
course there's different views and a lot
of views over the two years of course
there are but what we wanted to do at
conference what we took leaders say what
decisions we got to make in what order
first is what are you going to do about
the deal where we're at that stage now
if it's not good enough we'll vote
against it so that's decision number one
the deal Falls then the next question is
are you going to call for a general
election we've just dealt with that
obviously if that doesn't happen we need
to press on two other options such as a
public vote because having gone through
the first two options we need to look at
what would happen then and a conference
that's what we decided we would do we
can just have a look at what John wanted
all said on this this week the
Chancellor said if that's not possible
general election will be calling upon
the government then to join us in a
public vote that's the sequence I think
that will inevitably go through so do
you agree with John MacDonald then that
it could be inevitable well I think John
is going through exactly the same
process as me looking at as he says if a
general election is not possible then
options such as a public vote will have
to be looked at and that's what we
decided at our Party conference which
was would you like there to be a second
referendum I would like to have
something far better than we've got at
the moment this deal is a bad deal and
frankly to have got to a situation where
at the integration where the second
referendum be far better than where we
are at the minute well we'll have to see
when we get there but it's far better
than this deal here we are almost at the
end of the negotiating period with a
deal which is it looks as though it's
not going to get the confidence of
Parliament that is a huge failure and
the Primus does run the clock down so if
we get to a question of a public vote we
get to a question of a referendum it'll
be because the option of a deal that I
think could have been negotiated has
been taken off the table by the prime
minister who will have failed to put
something before Parliament that we can
have confidence in so in a sense she's
pushing these other options by the
failure to have got the option of a deal
that Parliament could support if if a
second referendum does happen what do
you think should be on the ballot paper
well we're gonna have to decide that as
a parliament if we get to that stage but
I've always been very clear that the
option of remain out to be on that
ballot paper how about the option they
do
should that be on as well well I would
be worried about that because I do think
No Deal will be catastrophic for the
country and I don't think people have
necessarily thought through all the
implications of No Deal if you've got no
deal you've got no trading relationship
with your most important set of trading
partners but you've also got no security
arrangements no arrangements for dealing
with counterterrorism before I was a
member of parliament as Director of
Public Prosecutions
and I was the UK rep in Euro just which
everybody will be pleased and as where
we share information about terrorist
activities etc the idea of getting to a
state where we're not participating in
those sort of arrangements I think is
something that whether you voted leave
or remain you wouldn't want so we
shouldn't be casual about No Deal it has
huge risks for our country just taking
what you're saying there I mean some
people would say if the two options on
the ballot paper were remain and Tory's
may steal then that's not really
reflecting what many people feel well
I'm not stating a fixed position here
we're not at that stage of the exercise
we're at the first stage which is
obviously the deal all I'm pointing out
and it's a point really for the vote in
nine days is that the option of no deal
or going for no deal
carries huge risk for our country I
don't actually think that this Prime
Minister will move to a no deal
situation she knows the risks she she's
very serious about counterterrorism and
security I don't think when she stands
up if she loses this vote that she's
likely to say I'm now going to take the
country off the cliff I'm going to go to
the No Deal scenario and then just
finally I'm a little late on the show
we'll be hearing from Nick Bowles who's
pushing for this idea of a kind of
Norway plus staying in a single market I
mean is that something that you think
labour could support well obviously we'd
have to hear what Nick says about it
he's put in a number of different ways
this idea of a Norway I mean I went to
Norway to study the Norway model as it's
called for for
all days and I didn't think it would
really work very well for the United
Kingdom it obviously works well for
Norway and when it was put as a
proposition to Parliament we didn't get
a majority and the Prime Minister says
she's not interested in it so
considerate then or is it something that
you you just don't think well at the
moment we need to see quite how it's put
but at the moment I'm not sure that it's
something that's very attractive but I
think what you're seeing now is that as
we run into this vote people are saying
well what other options are there I
think the person who needs to answer
that question is the Prime Minister okay
you could argue as well that she's been
slightly hamstrung by put a divider
Parliament as well so well she had the
snap election and lost her majority so I
mean it's it's not you know just
Parliament I get to the Prime Minister
actually she's the author Oh misfortune
okay okay that's Donna thank you very
much thank you